Hello everybody!
My name is Markiplier
and welcome back to Five Nights at Freddy's: Sister Location
Hand Unit: Press the red button now to administer a controlled shock.
WAAAT?!
WHY DO I WANT DANCYPANTS TO BE MAD AT ME?! *Ballora: erm im not mad..!*
TH- Hand Unit: For text only press 3,
TH- Hand Unit: For other options press 4.
THERE'S NO NUMBERZZZZZZ!!!!!!!!!
Hey! BABEY!!!!!
BABEY!!!!!!!!
BABEY!!! COME BACK!!!!
*Boop*
*Error*
Uh-oh
Baby: I don't recognize you... (nope nope nope nope nope nope)
Baby: You are new... (nope nope nope nope nope nope nope nope nope nope nope nope)
Baby: I remember this... scenario. (nope nope nope nope nope nope nope nope nope nope nope nope nope nope nope nope nope nope nope nope nope nope nope nope)
Who's out there??
Who wants to face me? :D
In a battle to the death? D:
I'm literally cornered right now -_-
Bidybab: Hello in there~ Mark: O_O
Babeh? *MARK WHY THAT WORD AGAIN*
Da-na-na-na-na-na-na-na-na
Ballora
Da-na-na-na-na-na-na-na
Don't kill me!
Da-na-NA-NA-NA-NUN! *LOL*
You don't need to worry about me..
I just need to worry about me D:
And don't mind the yelling,
I YELL WHEN I'M NERVOUS!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!
We did it!
We're the best in the world!
And, we are friends! ;)
For- oh- ever. ok. :(
Hand Unit: Thank you for selecting
Hand Unit: Exotic butters
Heh heh hueah
Oh god is baby on the way? *YAS MARK :D*
*Loading celebration.exe*
WOOOOOOOO!
Yeah!
Fuck yeah!
I did it!
Yaa!!
I got my exotic butters! :D
YES! :DD
oh the sweet taste of vic-....
*Popcorn and angry munching*
Ain't this just a son of a bitch? *yes it is mark :P*
Well I did it!
Place the crown upon my head...-
and then call me...
THE
KING!!!!
OF FIVE NIGHTS AT FREDDY'S!